what makes a good story what makes a
good story a good story is gonna be
here's the thing with a movie I do this
there's this thing called the skin jump
that I talked about that last time
good I'll talk about this time a skin
jump is where we as the audience jump
onto the screen and become the
protagonist in the story and a good
story has some sort of a fantasy that it
doesn't have to be a positive fantasy
that we want to explore in our life so
we skin jump and we are Eliot riding his
bicycle with ET and it flies you know
and that is like one of those moments
where if you were to turn the camera on
the audience and watch what watch the
audience they would all be just
overjoyed because we're all Elliott in
that scene for that moment and if we're
looking at a movie that's a where we can
become Indiana Jones and do the amazing
adventure thing and we basically jump
from the audience onto the screen which
means we need a character to jump into
and a good story is about a character
that fulfills some sort of dream
fulfillment some sort of fantasy the
audience has and a the reason why a film
is a hit is because it ends up hitting
the dream fulfillment elements of a lot
of people and so if you can figure out
the zeitgeist of what the audience what
people are dreaming about right now
that's that thing that's gonna pull us
onto the screen but it doesn't have to
be a positive thing often I did a film
noir class here and the film noir often
jumps us into people that do bad things
because we all sometimes secretly want
to do bad things but we can't so you
know we all want to you know there's a
lot of movies about career criminals
because we all sometimes want to break
the law there are a lot of movies about
people that do terrible awful things
that kill people that cue horrible
bosses that kill their bosses are trying
to do bad things because we have that
thing going on inside of us that's the
the dream fulfillment of that story so a
good movie is dream fulfillment to the
audience the audience fantasizes about
something we hopefully as as part of
that audience as members of that
audience we fantasize about some of
those things
to you a weird movie is when somebody
has their dream fulfillment you go what
kind of a sick weirdo is that dream and
you see those sometimes and go what's
going on here but but a good story is
gonna take it's gonna take that it's
gonna allow the audience to jump into
that character and then take that
character on an adventure to be a good
adventure it could be a bad adventure
but we're gonna go along with that story
and it's so that means there's gonna be
a great conflict in there someplace
that means often you know the the things
that often happens is romance of some
sort of another because even if it's you
know et is a boy and his dog story but
the dogs an alien and there is no more
unconditional love than from your dog or
you know I don't know your cat loves you
but your dog loves you at no matter what
so that's something we can fantasize
about we can get into that story we can
understand that story and jump into
Elliott's life with et and you know it's
the guy that brings the kids that bring
some of the pet that you know mom
doesn't want and has to hide it in the
closet and you know all those things you
know I found a stray dog
but the stray dogs an alien and now the
dog catcher wants him the dogcatchers
keys he's the guy from the government so
it's basically it's taking that story
and finding them you take on that story
because he that could have been a just a
dog story but by making it the alien
we're now telling the story we've
already heard we're telling a story
that's new that's different that gives
us a different experience than we've had
before enough that even answers the
question
you